so the first novel I wrote I wrote it in
a closet and that first closet was
literally three feet long and two feet
wide
he was basically gave me a warning that
like your creativity and your prolific
Ness the enemy of that the thing that
will steal it
is you get older it's not your age your
mind it's not it's not any different
your mind is anything just get sharper
sharper and better but it's distractions
it's distractions and it's distractions
which manifests it in a thousand emails
a day yup it manifested people calling
you it's manifested in someone becoming
sort of popular or well-known suddenly
everybody wants you to speak or do this
or do that we started the grotto and we
dreamed of a day that it could be a
bigger thing and we're now going into
our twenty-third year we have 125
writers at second and Bryant yeah and
three classes a night and the writers
can make money teaching which is great
for them boom what's up everyone welcome
to simulation we are sitting down with
Poe Brunson how are you thanks for
coming out of the show yeah thanks Ann I
appreciate you so much because you are
an extremely distinguished author plus
you have inspired so many other authors
plus you are very Polymathic in the way
that you think about the world and
civilization and I want to talk about
kind of I want to talk about you and how
you got to where you're at but I also
really want to talk about your visions
for where we're going and how we can
inspire the next generation you know
there's a lot to unpack right yeah even
even after demo day which was just a
couple days ago for indie bio which Poe
has gotten much more close with indie
bio and there was this there were
there's this moment when when I was like
oh you know Poe is like just the multi
Appling airy writer and that when we
were talking in the group you myself and
Kayla were talking at the very end of
the night the way that you were
articulating your thoughts about people
and automation and and meaning and
morals and ethics it was I would love to
to talk about that at some point in the
conversation maybe a little bit torus
and Poe who the hell are you
you know how did you even discover that
writing was something that you cared
about and you've lived here like 30
years you said in Sam yeah I moved here
in 86 so quickly that's 32 years from LA
no I grew up in Seattle in Seattle
that's right yeah I grew up in Seattle I
came down and go to Stanford then I
moved here yeah I grew up when I was
growing up I was a math guy and but I
didn't really like hanging out with the
math people that much and I was alright
being on the math team gonna state math
championships and the wrestling team ban
and that kind of thing but it was also a
soccer player and sort of family life
was a bit unstable and why was it
unstable
we were like the first family on the
block where the first family I ever we
were the second I'd ever heard of an
inci I grew up in Seattle
for parents got divorced and it had
happened to a friend of my mom's first
as a child like growing up like you were
like the first of a wave right a wave
that would last 3040 years and a wave of
Kip families getting split up
Oh dual households interests having
trouble getting the bill seen Poe is
illustrating what would look like on a
on a graph over time as the divorce rate
probably starting at around 25% or
something fairly low really low
yeah and a lower
even 10% maybe 12 for some well that's
how you think about it but normally
people were on these statistics over a
20-year time period so a divorce rate
even today were divorces down but at a
peak when people would say half of all
it was right it's yeah absolutely was
but it would really that's not how they
measure it they measured over a 20-year
period so it's actually only it's like
it's much less than half and by those
actual measures but yeah basically
because nobody is getting more snow to
Vegas get married to get divorced and
have that count as a divorce
no does kind of that does count yeah
it's the it's that people can't measure
forever cuz you've stopped in time so
you sort of say how how many marriages
survive twenty years is like the classic
Census Bureau statistics stop for time
but that that got up to like forty one
percent at one point okay you know
meaning if someone who lasted 25 years
said they got divorced it wasn't being
counted in that yes yeah I have an older
and younger brother okay
and growing up yeah nobody was getting
divorced no one talked about divorce it
was happening to some portion of society
but it was very rare and then all of a
sudden someone my mom knew got divorced
and my husband knows the biggest thing
was no way no one knew back then how to
how to do that so they lost all their
friends because it was frowned upon they
were frowned upon by their families my
parents continued to fight the cost of
divorce to maintain two households all
of a sudden neither household could
really pay the bills with three boys we
were we fought all the time I mean we
were close but also fought all the time
like and just the economic splits the
economics of the split is insane if it's
under one house it's so much easier yeah
if it's in two houses and know everybody
lowers their socioeconomic status right
that is insane yeah well anyway it was
that was my childhood but I I got away I
wanted to get away
I came down to Stanford I came here how
did the Stanford how did that happen was
a good grades in school was my math
thing it was a math yeah and then I did
like I remember taking this philosophy
class I got bad grades in every class
that required me to write like I
couldn't write a history paper I
couldn't write an English paper but my
senior year I took a philosophy class
and somehow that enabled a spark of me
to take my creativity I would just do
weird stuff I was like I wish I would
like I've friends growing up that like
you know we would do computers because
of the mass stuff but I would be like
I'm not really my thing you know and
they would go on to like run Microsoft
and stuff like that and I just be like I
want to like make weird sculptures out
of found objects like I did you know my
creativity was very unformed and I
didn't know anybody or no one in my
family to ever done anything creative
and but my mom growing up her boyfriend
for a long time was a penniless writer
so the idea of being like my mom loved
intellectuals wasn't quite one herself
but it was absolutely like you know he
there were lots of periods of time where
he couldn't she kicked him out one time
because he couldn't afford a roll of
toilet paper and you know like that's
what yeah it still is in some ways but
at least you could say my stuff is up on
the internet like back then all you
could say is on a piece of paper I typed
it out yeah and then he got you got it
digitally which is great and then also
there are now incredible companies like
patreon that enable artists to get paid
by building up followings that can then
support them for really good work which
is super super helpful okay so what tell
you so much so yeah so my diss
philosophy class I remember
sending in for my application to
Stanford a 50-page dialog I had written
for no reason it was just like something
I did on the Saturday between Plato and
Socrates and I imagined like how they
would try to one-up each other that's
funny I sent that in with my math scores
to Stanford and yeah that's great but my
math stuff was that you know at the
ceiling effects there so the but then I
got a Stanford in I test i did a math
like one semester and i was like i don't
know what you'd do with math in the real
world like i couldn't imagine it did no
one ever bothered to tell me and i
didn't go around asking either and my
parents didn't try to tell me what to do
I ended up doing economics and then my
junior year my girlfriend who was a
senior wrote you know it was writing an
artist I said what are you doing all the
time so I'm writing an honors thesis I'm
like oh that sounds fun like what do you
do like you know you have to come up
with a theory in your attic yeah that
sounds good so I wrote a thesis and then
the next fall I wrote another thesis and
then the winter I wrote another thesis
and the spring unnoted thesis and I was
studying Japanese economics with this
guy masa Aoki he's passed away now but
he was one of the leading thinkers and
understanding difference in economic
systems around the world can learn a
little about these theses as well as
mosses thinking the way you know think
about what we've learned about assembly
lines where workers have ideas and the
workers worked in teams and everybody's
idea was valued so if a worker said you
know if instead of making the cart this
high
we made the cart this high I could do
things better and so Japanese
manufacturing learning-by-doing was the
concept at the time really learning by
doing and also sort of this meant ideas
and a little bit of cooperative
team-based working where we as opposed
to us were told
reductionist multiple moved around
within a team and two different chores
and jobs and tasks and it learned so the
beginning of multidisciplinary ISM as a
rejection of the sort of breaking down
all work into attacks on ax me and super
specialization so that powered like
eighties economic theory and powers my
existence so I was studying multi
cross-cultural economics and I was
interested mostly in the way that not
that culture affected economically as
economics was destroying culture with
sort of mask economics in then I did
this little specialization which was I
called it learning by using what would
now today we would understand his
customer feedback right and the entire
all that stuff so the whole chain of
stuff that one-to-one marketing in the
90s now custom development innovation
today learn by using instead of customer
feedback
it was learn by using read and learn by
doing and and I applied all of learning
by doing thinking to learning by using
and developed an economic theory around
it and Stanford wanted me to come get a
PhD program and they just sit out of the
blue like hey you know you could stay
here for next seven years you get a free
ride or whatever and I was like I
actually have this weird feeling that I
the reason I wrote for Economic DC's was
not because I love economics because I
think I love to write yes and like who
works for Honors theses like kind of fun
yeah and so I moved to New York and I
lived on a friend's couch and I wrote a
novel yeah and it I wrote it was a novel
and it was a love story of some sort and
the end of the summer I borrowed a
typewriter from another friend and I
typed up the novel that have been hand
writing and I got about 3/4 away through
typing it when I realized it sucks it's
I'm no writer and I moved back to San
Francisco and I went downtown and I got
a job and I hated it and I quit it and I
ended up in finance and I ended up as a
bond on the bond sales floor at first
Boston in the peak of the 80s and I just
I wasn't there because I wanted that to
my career I just I didn't even know what
I was just it I actually just had fun
went to work at 4:30 in the morning and
moved to go to bed moved a billion
dollars of money a day a billion the day
yeah and because of my bath background
that kind of math Act we were doing the
first ribs but it's just really not that
hard math and even though it would the
getting of a synthetic instrument so I
sold a lot of those first synthetic
instruments I know I was gonna be very
clear I was an assistant so I made
eighteen thousand a year and I got like
bonus jacks from sales people who wrote
me checks for like ten grand or five
grand like damn so I made about thirty
grand when the guys I was working for
and doing all this work for we're making
millions and even then they were like
again the same thing what we think you
should come same thing at Stanford we
think you're great at this you're the
best we were seeing come stay and I was
like again I'd gone back to like Rick
was sleeping four hours a night and
writing a novel again yeah and I what
said no I'm gonna
I got a it's come back to me I have to
figure this out and I enrolled at state
in night school and for seven years
wrote at state and did other did other
jobs and kind of eventually like to try
to control this I got into small book
publishing and I became chairman of a
book distributor and I was associate
publisher of a small press here and
built helped build a small breasts
community yeah and then
one day I finally my writing didn't suck
it takes a long time it's a long can't I
takes and it takes so much time you have
to invest so much into learning how to
write crazy we've been writing our whole
lives and yet really communicating like
I mean like you have to write four hours
a day for seven years yeah to get any
good at it yeah I mean not that it
doesn't how long snake to be a great
doctor how long's a great video at
that's right I don't care it takes the
same amount of time don't just walk up
and start sinking threes it takes a long
time but we do grow up shooting threes
and we do grow up writings and we do we
don't grow up doing surgery yeah so but
it is a weird thing it's very very
frustrating and punishing that period of
your life when you're like like you
don't and there's a good four years
something that's also frustrating about
writing like you said 3/4 of a book yeah
and then going like I'm not going to
publish this right and because and I've
written so many drafts myself where I'm
just like I'm not going to publish this
and it takes it's like the marshmallow
experiment it takes patience until
you've wait and wait and write and write
and write until it looks good enough
that you love the way that you're
communicating and actually during
Peterson he broke down the way that he
writes in such a fascinating way cuz I'm
sure that you also write this way I
write this way once you've finished
writing a a even a sentence you might
write that sentence two or three or four
times with different work with
arrangements of it to see what is the
master so every sentence every sentence
every sentence of every page every page
of every book like people don't realize
like how much like because once I could
write on a computer you could write the
same sentence 50 times if you needed to
and you didn't have to have a record of
it or you could save some of them
because they're better people don't
realize like that's literally what
you're doing you're like iterating hyper
design constantly you know and like
every thought like
and should have a comma or not I have a
comma should use this word I just like
and just getting it's it's such a
perfectionist art and we don't we don't
characterize it as that right we kind of
characterize this romantic art but in
fact like the degree of perfectionism
that you bring to like every little
detail and slowly you attune yourself to
like to doing this and understanding
that this is what you do that takes
about two or three years and then your
your writing is just as good as the
stuff you would read in the New York or
you'd feel like it's just as good like
why am i why isn't doing my stuffs just
as good why the might as that stuff
you'd read elsewhere like it feels like
your stuff is just as good but but most
commonly people don't really have a
point of view yet they don't really have
a voice it's polished right it's
accomplished and book editors you know
in boxes are just packed with this stuff
that's all kind of polished and good and
but it doesn't really have like
something distinct about it and learning
not to learning to push through periods
of imitation to finding your original
sort of voice obviously that originality
is comes from you know stealing so much
but finding it you know I have a very
interesting question that I think you'd
like enjoy do you think as a proportion
of population we have more books now
than we did you know a thousand or even
longer ago even a hundred years ago
weight as a proportion population years
ago before the printing press was
invented hundred or even a thousand I'm
curious of both so as a percentage of
population I mean a thousand years ago
we had what like a hundred million
people on the planet something really
low yeah and so as a percentage of
population how many people were
publishing books per day versus today
out of seven and a half billion people
how many people are publishing books per
day I'm just I'm so number of books is
just still continues to drastically
increase and and as a but as a
percentage of population has that ink
has that increase as a percentage of
population because it feels like we live
in
book noise yeah as we live in social
media Norris we live in book noise and
that's why I'm constantly trying to
parse that noise to find the best books
yeah to read what I'm so contribute to
the noise I want to write the best book
right like when I started in publishing
in 1989 there were 50,000 books coming
out of here by time I left in 95 is
80,000 was easily over a hundred
thousand and now it's well over 300
thousand I got a year it was also
interesting to go back and look at the
60s globally this is just in the US
that's in the u.s. in the 60s for so
much fewer books were published I don't
remember the number I want to say it was
like 15,000 so so like the good books
stood out and people read them and books
were like back then almost like movies
were 10 years up to 10 years ago up to
10 years ago people saw the movies the
movies that came out people saw them and
if they hadn't seen them they'd read
enough money you could go to lunch with
a group of people and you could all talk
about movies because enough people
around the table had seen the movies or
read enough about the mood to have a
conversation with a shared experience
right yeah today it's it's hard to find
people who've read the same book as you
it's it's hard it's even now that's
happening to movies we're just so many
movies come and go and people haven't
seen them so there's a there's an
increase in amount of opportunity of
knowledge that people can go and immerse
themselves into that's why nowadays when
you're like have you seen Game of
Thrones and they're like no I haven't
and then they'd be that's because
they've been reading a book I mean while
the other person's been playing soccer
meanwhile the other person's been
learning how to tweak a robot and write
in class yeah so it's interesting that
we don't have this one of the things
that's happening with the atomization
and fracture ization of our culture is
that we don't have these unified things
I mean everybody tuned into the Brett
Kavanaugh hearings right it was I think
that was great for you know to like
great to everybody cared and everybody
watched something it was like a like
what the Superbowl was
when I was a kid but everyone thought
they had a perspective when they were
not a research scientist on the matter
which I thought was nobody nobody went
knew both of those two people for 20
years to understand who they were right
all the evidence but everyone thought
they knew so no but at least it was the
sherry spirit but my point is that it
shouldn't take I mean that's it's too
bad that that's like that's the example
that came to my mind because it was such
a it was you're right but you know like
a shared experience around it Twitter is
basically the consciousness of the
planet it's kind of its kind of weird
innocent it may be the it or the aid of
the planet yeah yeah you know okay now
can I take us to when you started
sharing the literary yeah can I take us
back there yeah and and and so then how
did you transition to the SF writers
grotto yeah so I sold my first novel and
to Random House and I just thought a
small press was gonna publish any worse
teaches about the novel so first yes of
my first my first book bombed that was
called bomba deers it was written in the
style of catch-22 I I arrived at the
style of writes about catch-22 style
yeah just a second so that's why we were
like so I was spent you know three or
four years in this phase where I'm like
feeling my stuff was just as good and I
tapped into like I came from a school of
writing I call it the era of minimalism
and I was trying to write like that when
really I was like a polymath and I was a
maximalist living in an era of
minimalism and I finally was realizing
this and it was a writer named William
Kittredge who told me you're talking
about like writing a sentence right and
how every writer pauses in every
sentence at the end of every sentence at
the end of every paragraph trying to
figure out what to do next and what
writers do in that moment how they
decide what to do next now in acting
from acting there was an idea that like
you sort of think what would the care
Derr in the scene do next what's genuine
to the character so that was one guiding
another school thought was where does
the words what are the writing wanna go
and some very really good literary
writers of the 90s were that's what the
the song and of where where do the words
want to take you mm-hmm
and William Kittredge told me to get
angry no one had ever told me that
before to look into things that made me
angry
oh yes it's out of self not to
necessarily write about them but to
channel that anger into what I was
writing yeah and all of a sudden my work
had that even though it was fiction had
this sort of nonfiction commentary state
of the world and I began to rebel
against every rule of minimalism yeah
and I finally decided to write a book
where I would break every rule and every
sentence every time so for example in
the 90s every book would have it would
there be a passage and then there'd be a
white space it's to symbolize end of
seeing passing of time you would you
wouldn't have to write the boring stuff
about then he left the room and then he
walked into a new room it's just kind of
like like the way of film cuts right it
says white space so I said I was gonna
have no white no white space so there
was it was like it was an era where
nobody used adverbs adverbs are the
worst like adjectives were bad but
adverbs were the worst so I was I was
gonna pack my book full of this kinetic
adverb play whoa
you never show not tell write show not
tell she was gonna tell and you don't
write about the world of business
because that has if that's that world
and we want to have our own literary
world we wanted to think about what
business was doing to the world and I
was like no I'm gonna write her but I
was on Wall Street I'm gonna write about
how business is destroying the world and
so I wrote I it was was not in any way
like a Roman
play of my time as a bond salesman it
was really an absolute abstraction of
that but and I also brought comedy back
I was really pissed minimalism nothing
was ever funny and I one day I was just
like I was down in Swat inhale Mexico
and I was at this motel and then the you
know like the lobby they had a had
nothing to read I got head catch-22 and
I was reading to say look this is so
funny and he was is an absurdist take on
war and being bomber pilots in World War
two and he'd made that funny and putting
it and an incredible damnation of the
entire thing at the same time yeah yeah
and that's how you get ideas thick
satire is humor sent on a moral mission
and I was like why doesn't anyone write
shot are so I wrote a very dark
satirical novel about how Wall Street
was destroying the world called bomba
deers where I the metaphorically
symbolized the bond salesman as the
person who is sending bombs into the
financial system that were blow up years
later oh [ __ ] yeah that kind of
diversion a lot of the 2008 crisis yeah
so this was I was writing this in the
early nineties predicting coming
financial disasters yes and there's a
fabulous term our slopes they had had me
sit sell Oh be careful the marshmallow
just you know because that things hold
bunk I'll tell you about that later but
I want to learn about you for yeah yeah
okay the five kids had ADHD we know not
now so in the marshmallow test the
original thing okay but isn't it a very
clear in your own life that there is a
pretty good amount of delayed
gratification that you can explore in
order to maximize your outcomes yeah but
the idea that you could measure that
constructing kids when they were five is
what was just bunk but but it but even
today it's like I I can reach over and
grab my device and go and surf the
Instagram or I can open my notebook yeah
and I can write some ideas down there's
these different ways I know all that
absolutely
yeah so that what we mean by the
marshmallow test is 100% valid even if
the original Walter Mischel test was not
Bombardier so Bombardier so show not
tell so the first line I was supposed to
just you know show not tell instead I
just told I was like first line is it
was a filthy profession but the money
was addicting and they were all going to
hell and then I just went from there
yeah and that's good I broke every rule
you like wrote the thesis in the first
cent yeah the first just say what it is
and then and then move on and move on
and you know and I captured their
attention it did and so Random House
bought it and then it would go on to be
sold in 20 languages and and but before
it was coming out my close friend Ethan
waters had also sold his book which was
a debunking of the recovered memory
movement of the time and the writer
Ethan Canin
was working on his third book and he and
we decided to form the writers gratis le
and that was started with the three of
us which within a month became the six
of us Josh Kornbluth filmmaker David
Monroe and English writer named Tessa
Souter who's now a really great jazz
singer out of New York and we started
the grotto and we dreamed of a day that
it could be a bigger thing and we're now
going into our twenty-third year we have
125 writers at second and Bryant yeah
and three classes a night and the
writers can make money teaching which is
great for them and despite rent going up
I mean back in the original grotto we
was each of us is paying about 230 bucks
a month for our office today the average
writers spending 230 bucks a month for
an office so they might share that
office but we've managed all this time
without any grants just by using the
space really really creatively
to find a creative community for the
writers who want to be there yeah and
it's become enormous ly improved in its
diversity not fully there yet but it's
incredible yeah and we we the the
writing life has changed there was a
good 15 10 years there where it was
people who wrote full-time and all
working professional writers but now
only a small sub sector can sort of
write all the time they also teach or
consult or do other work to kind of make
a living at it so and we're at a really
good transition point the grotto now
where we have a new group of the writers
and a process by which we're sort of
moving to nonprofit status and we just
kind of ran it as a community I was we
were just like for a long time like
roommates first it was six roommates
then it was nine roommates then it was
twenty three roommates
then it was 35 then it was 50 then it
was 70 at a hundred we're like because
we better like like it's hard to
remember what the rules are or what the
security code is like so so but the
writers corrado has been a been a great
thing so many great writers have come
out of there 23 years yeah that's I love
that yeah I love it when we can stand
the test of time though it's anti
fragile and hopefully it stays another
23 years like I hope so that's the plan
you know and that was I mean we were I
mean frankly we were I mean every we
were that's our fifth location at every
location we were booted out you know the
rent was gonna be tripled and we would
be booted out and we would have to get
bigger and be really creative to find a
new space and you know pack more writers
in and find a way to do it and we
managed to make it so far which is not
easy with what's happened obviously to
the rents around the city I'm really
happy that I got to come to the writers
grotto and I wasn't even meeting you I
was meeting David Ewing
in there and he has a very cool office
there he's he's authored a lot of books
as well and I like how you're talking
about the diversity of people at the
writers grotto that also helps you guys
can help each other become better
writers what what is it about writing
you were talking about it earlier it was
so fascinating when you were just
speaking about this but there we were we
were talking about how one when one
writes a book they they go through this
process of iteration iteration iteration
and you have to you can't be addicted to
these devices and read books and know
you think that they don't work at the
same time no the best writing I've ever
had in my life was at the 10-day
meditation retreat yeah by far the best
writing I've ever had and most creative
thinking because there's no there's no
technology and there's no there's no
speaking so you're all in word yeah and
so um and then you then you started so
I'll just tell you a couple things about
me yeah so just for it's worth so the
first novel I wrote I wrote it in a
closet and that first closet was
literally three feet long and 2 feet
wide and I had up a little metal chair
and it was an old Mac 512 on a little
stool in front of me with the lap with
the keyboard like on my lap and and I
would close the door
and it was black in there and I'd played
one song for nine months yeah that
became this sort of block out noise
exactly and when we started the grotto
my office had a little old tiny bathroom
in there and there was a base the toilet
was behind me I had a little chair
I made a makeshift plywood desk in this
bathroom with Anna curtain at that time
to make it dark yeah and I wrote my
second novel there and then at every
grotto I have a writing closet anything
closet yeah so I had my office but I
write in a closet and to to block
everything
everything yeah like don't bring my
phone in there and I have to go into my
world of what I'm writing yes and I love
it though so yeah you can't write if
you've got this thing right you don't
know there's no such thing yep
nope not real writing like and so it was
amazing that all these books are getting
published because I don't how people are
writing them to be honest or this is
writing without thing one thing that I
think has in very interestingly helped
there is a lot of writing without
thinking going on that's why there's so
much noise I think there's also
something fascinating about being able
to take the sentence and then go and
copy and paste it five times and then
because that's faster than writing it
out by hand so then the digital has
helped in a sense but also digitally
when you're connected to the Internet
then you go and you look up a word and
then the next thing you know you're
browsing the internet for stuff and
you're like distracted from your writing
yeah so that's why the pen and paper is
still really handy so there's all this
nuance I love how you talk about your
your your lyric locker closet yeah desk
yeah just this big you know just like it
would kneel we were in the olden done
count hospital for five years or so
where I had a red kitty corner to the
Twitter building on fell Street there
and now it's a big condo tower or
something but and it it was more fun to
a parking garage and at the back of the
roof of the parking garage was the
office that Ethan I had and in the back
of the office literally it was an old
count it was a dog kennel about about
this size and I put up like a plastic
door and my desk was only like 12 inches
why like just enough for my computer
exactly and my chair was surrounded by
concrete painted white and I did realize
that like writing all the time all day
long in the dark isn't so good for your
life hormonal balance yeah there's
something in your eyes so I learned to
sort of keep a little light on yeah
but I was staring into a screen all day
too so I don't necessarily see the eyes
yeah but I yeah so written all my books
like that
yes attached what's it catch-22 so a
catch-22 is essentially oh man
so it's never stated what is a catch-22
is in the book cash pointer they just
describe catch-22 is they are
essentially infinite loops or circular
systems or impossible logics or the
snake that's eating its tail
it's a catch-22 is essentially an
oxymoron or on some level or hypocrisy
but really it's more a circular loop of
logic and like I'm gonna fly to LA and
then when I get to LA I'm gonna fly to
SF but then every time I land in SF I
have to fly to LA yeah it's like the
writing a line of code that just
constantly yeah so an infinite loop in
code is one where it's it's a variable
is is dependent upon another variable
which has have been on another variable
which is depending on the original
original variable and then you you you
end up the computer doesn't know where
to go when it gets into the infinite
loop and and why is that writing style
really important because somehow when
you see it and feel the examples they
they call attention to you know it's
like the the absurdity of thinking we
have it all thought out and the the it
destroys the it calls attention to the
to the fact that we have some things
figured out but not others and we do a
lot of things because we were there they
were automatic to us we were told to do
them that way and we don't realize how
insane you know sort of insane they are
sometimes
and yeah I think that that that kind of
star writing in that mechanism is is a
little bit like I haven't seen many
examples of it in the last 10 years or
so it's interesting to think about it
actually
it was prevalent in a lot of my work
until I started writing about social
science in which case I actually tried
to use science and and point things out
rather than suggest that science was
absurd for even attempting to explain
human behavior you know which at some
point I felt like like even when I was
with nurture shock which introduces the
world to the concept of growth mindset
that was the first time well Carol Dweck
had been published her work in 1998 she
had been doing those experiments since
1984 she had tried to get some press it
had no traction when I discovered her
her book and sold 500 copies and all I
did was I mean I did a lot more but you
know basically in 2007 I took what she
had done and I wrote it differently than
she had written it same stuff I was true
to the science but I explained it a
little differently and all of a sudden
exploded was it with a little bit of
that bump on your bumper deers edge no
no I had taken that edge off so that
edge oh that's really interesting a good
question so I really had an edge yeah
until 2000 and then in 2000 I went down
to Hollywood to write and I was there
for a little while like nine months or
10 months or so and then I decided I
needed to find a way to reach the other
parts of my personality that weren't
coming across so myself it had been a
bit cynical or satirical mm-hmm
pointed but I'm also very compassionate
person yes I care about people and that
wasn't coming across in my writing and I
decided to write this book what should I
do with my life which became a number
one New York Times bestseller and all
that had told I traveled the country
telling people's life stories about how
they changed their life and I was doing
it as sort of a rebellion against maybe
the whole self-help thing or whatever
but it was like I wanted to really
describe people's psychological journeys
and it was a very empathic compassionate
book yeah it was not satirical or
cynical in the least it was very
different for a lot of my readers was
like what are you doing like this isn't
your not being funny well like this is
the polymath at work though this yes
really then I had like a couple million
new readers so exactly yeah and I did
and I went on to do that with another
social documentary about people's lives
family stories and then and then to them
I did that again then I started doing
writing about social science and and all
of them will apply and again it was sort
of like but I was what was happening in
the mid to that and the mid arts was
there was a lot of popular writing done
sort of it was this like you would like
survey the science to try to explain a
phenomenon and in the end you could sort
of sort of wink and laugh about how
science will never really figure this
stuff out it's fun that they're sort of
trying you know and I was like no I
don't like you guys characterizing
science this way like you just now
listening to this real scientists like
some scientists can't figure things out
some scientists are just like economists
but some people have figured out real
things and I wanted to write you started
to do that and so that was a whole
nother voice so when I was writing about
Carol Dweck for the first time I was my
first social science article and it went
on to get the top award for the American
Association commands from a science and
and it was the thesis of it well that
was that was the that article ended the
self-esteem movement and ended the era
of kids being told their how great they
were and how smart they were and that
article around the world except in
France where they weren't doing this
began the understanding of highlighting
the importance as kids are forming their
view of themselves in the world of
effort and hard work yeah you know so
that whole body of work all came from
sort of was released through through
that article reinterpreting Carol
Dweck's
worked from literally from 1984 to 98
and she her book went on to sell a
million copies to you know like and and
everybody all the other scholars and and
writers who covered this space sort of
unlocked from yeah but all I did was
sort of rewrite the science a little bit
simpler cleaner yes it makes sense yes
and took away jargon and just and and
literally and get it gave actionable
relatable examples yeah of the whole
everyone gets a trophy thing yeah kids
got a [ __ ] work hard right they have
to learn how to become a master at
something in right they're not gonna
become a master if they're just not
investing they're not investing time
into learning skills and habits you know
things like that yeah yeah okay okay so
nurture shock crushed it okay I'm I'm
taking notes because I I just I'm loving
what I'm learning so I want to to have
so else so I'll just tell you this thing
which is that I nice was my first two
books were novels I can tell it's like
video is not enough for me and then on
top of that then you could re watch this
but then that takes time it's it's it's
very interesting I'm an
obsessive-compulsive note-taker
obsessive compulsive interviewer there's
these just very strange
Anker sees about me that I don't think
we'll ever go away it's good I actually
really like it because obviously when I
interview people I'm usually taking
notes and they're not doing it on cam or
something but even it's interesting
because because normally like I normally
people don't take notes when they're me
they interview me on camera right but
clearly you're thinking I like it
because it's like you're thinking and
it's very different than being viewed by
someone who's just trying to think of
the next question when this guy stops
talking which is your typical you know
everything from your morning show to
your radio shows different I like it
keep taking notes
thank you and we're going to keep having
this eccentric format of of discourse
yeah yeah and this is this is this is
what the future of an interlocutor looks
like yeah when they participate in
dialogue it's not about waiting for them
to finish to ask the next question there
is something about like some sort of a
what is a powerful question I can ask
but really it's a lot of it is about
engaging empathetic energetics but then
also you were just talking you said my
first two novels were and then you were
going yeah so so they were fiction right
and then I started doing this work for
magazines just to like pay the bills I
was thinking about next book and I
didn't I'd always thought like I didn't
want to do nonfiction like well I had
just too much of an imagination I just
needed to you know do that forever but
it was they were take the magazine
assignments for taking me places and
making me talk to people and I actually
found nonfiction to be told to my
surprise da but naive person I was as
really interesting a creative challenge
as anything because you have this
constraint yeah which is that you have
to tell the truth yes you have to be
bounded by fact yes but I was a writer
as a quoit person I wanted to write very
creatively but within the boundaries of
a fact and that was a it's like you know
a creative exercise where we say well
you can't draw anything
you can only draw you know holding a
pencil with your left hand
well now it's fun I know you have some
constraints right it's like you so
within that box of constraints actually
found really new sides to my creativity
and my writing style and also then I
made this vow I actually said I'm I
actually felt like as a novel writer
that I had written a book that it wasn't
like my whole time on Wall Street but it
was a total absurdist and but but it was
clearly an extension of that
and then my second novel was set in
Silicon Valley and it was in the sort of
tension between real hardcore engineers
versus what was happening to the
marketing of the valley and the tension
between the creative engineers who are
really doing something amazing and then
how their stuff was being marketed like
as as goofy and stupid it had been the
whole thing was move itted by these
interviews I had done and when they
first come up with parallel processing
Intel's original pentium had parallel
processing in it but Microsoft software
couldn't take advantage of it so half
the [ __ ] chip was sitting there doing
nothing yet they were selling it during
Super Bowls and I was like this is great
like this to spend time with these
engineers hardcore you know chipset
designers who had made this these
breakthroughs and then how better they
felt that they're like like their
amazing machine was being sold to the
world as this great thing right but in
fact it was throttled by the software
and half of its potential was being
wasted and to me that was a metaphor for
a generation half of its potential was
being wasted half of how are we going to
say the world of half of our potentials
being wasted I love that phrase and can
we stay on that for a little bit because
that's been my whole thing and all along
is human
and what we're doing with how we get
people to doing the right things that's
what what I doing that my people don't
see this through line but my first two
books were saying my first book was
about Wall Street it was like basically
smart people stopped working there your
waste you're not doing anything you're
only making it worse next book was about
Silicon Valley so like this great center
of innovation of the world nevertheless
we're still wasting half of the
processing power even here right and
then what I do in life was about telling
people to get on to a more meaningful
life I'm more meaningful things you can
do with your work you know listen to
that voice you have and follow it and be
doing the right things in this world
then the next couple books like nurture
shock was where I began to think about
the next generation how we were gonna
rule in the next generation and I needed
to write this science book describing
actual child development science not
what we thought it was or was society
wanted to say because of our biases and
so that we could sort of help the next
generation and and and what I'm doing
now is we haven't even got to but it's
all about like you know where do we how
do we guide people to having the right
impact on the world so that's really
even though it my books look like all
over the map of every form and every
voice in every tone and great but
they're in fact united by this through
line which is this is the thing I really
care about which is what are people
doing about what's happening to the
world and how we're gonna fix it and I
like Vivienne Ming taught me at like
four years ago maximize human potential
yeah and I'm just stuck with that phrase
forever and when you say that half of
the potential is being wasted in my head
I'm thinking about that I'm pretty sure
I told you and Kayla this when we were
hanging out a couple nights ago but that
if one's attention is positioned towards
the devices like this if their attention
is position this way towards the social
apps then their attention is not being
positioned the other way and the other
way can
be creative endeavoring such as music
are writing sculpting business execution
invention you can go to nature bathe in
oceans or in forests you can go spend
time with your friends and family asking
them deep questions writing a down of
the complex perspectives that exist on a
specific issue so you can learn how to
carry more perspectives and speak about
that which is a thesis of the book
stealing fire by Steven Kotler I can go
off but the fact that it is connecting
the world fantastic there's a lot of
really good stuff to it but we need to
honestly talk about how it's majorly
sacrificing human creativity for the
instantaneous lottery system that were
that we're doing and also the meaning in
life that is lost so it's economic
opportunity cost and its meaning cost
it's costing us meaning in life yeah
yeah so that's how I feel about this and
I'm so obsessed about it that it's one
of the one of the like twenty theses
that I'm trying to scrunch into a into a
book and movie yeah right now and and
I'm and I'm being more patient with it
Poe I used to be obsessively impatient
with it yeah and I learned to become
more patient with it yeah because it's
synthesizing information takes time it
does take time yeah yeah I mean like my
last book was published I don't know
three or four years ago and I decided
actually decided like really writ large
like I was like I was having a lot of
visions around where we were headed as a
society and I all felt like writing
about the present wasn't like wasn't
going to help and I also had a vision a
strong vision I still have around like
that a writer that this sort of lone
wolf rider the writer there's an
observer effect right so we know this
from mostly from quantum physics that to
measure an attempt to even look at all
in any way alters the phenomenon
and in social size is called the
Hawthorne effect people behave
differently if they're being watched or
mom that's what it is the Hawthorne
effect yeah and the media and writers I
think oh yeah an observer effect role in
society right shining back a mirror that
shows you something you've been
neglecting or different yes ma have you
been feeling that the observer effect
was weakening mmm that the observer
effect was weakening through a pollution
not through anything just just as you
say like there's always noise
interesting noise and people came a nerd
to it and also this thing yeah this
thing just like yeah I remember this
time like I did this thing it was a
story for New York Times Magazine and I
remember like when they would started to
release stuff early for the magnet so
you could read like on a Tuesday what
was gonna be in the Sunday magazine
online you had to go look find the link
and stuff and I did this it was a story
about how stress a short term
performance stress like on high-stakes
testing and SAT taking and kids knows oh
but it also relates to autism but it's
actually moderated by genotype and that
some kids some people need stress to
perform their best is based on how their
brain works and other people do not
perform best under stress they need a
less stressful mom to perform their
cognitive best and any sort of testing
of any sort is gonna buy us one
population anyway I wrote the story and
I remember like by like Wednesday before
it was being published it was number one
most emailed article in New York Times
right and it stayed that way through
Saturday and on Sunday it was published
and everybody could read it and it was
but by Monday it was gone
yeah and I had been done stuff just a
few years earlier where stuff like I did
one for New York where it was the number
one what's memorable for five years
right like all of a sudden the new cycle
of a big story was so short and and that
was that was five years ago like today
it would be it would you get an hour
yeah you know and that so not just the
deep thought but people who done deep
thought and were communicating them
there there was no way to stick yeah and
so I began to have this vision that like
writers needed to work with maybe
organizations or movements yeah to align
themselves in a way that it could not be
a good stick yes and and and that a
writer just trying to do their own
observer effect with an N of one that
you would you would have a be a billet
exactly a blend and that's when I began
looking for like around my thoughts
around the future and where we're headed
and how to and now stuff that that
that's part of why I miss pain it's not
time IND bio because that's like an
organization where I felt like working
with that team there and Arvind like
where our minds work really well
together but like that's a vision that
helps me feel like I'm not just being a
writer just doing this in the abstract
entirely yeah and don't you know I don't
know where that's headed but that that's
what it was literally like the result of
this long-term vision of like what's a
writer's role in our society and how do
we actually change to art change
people's minds in a way that they don't
just change back a minute later yeah
yeah so you you're describing the issue
that that we have with this art of this
artist or this writer or this this
information synthesizer gorgeous
synthesized ation of information that
then comes up as a blip and is gone yeah
and I think what one of the things that
we're really aiming to do with
simulation in the studio is we our first
goal up there on the left is Polymathic
educational platform data
and we want these records of these
conversations for anyone to be able to
go back and watch po talk about how the
hook to write a book or they can listen
to someone talk about how to 3d print an
organ alright and and so when we create
this massive database for young people
to be able to access and get inspired by
it that is that will hopefully be a blip
that can be accessed over time right but
i just-i it does it drives me nuts
thinking that's the half-assed potential
the half of our potential being wasted
right another one another example of
that is what we were talking about with
the with facing the attention economy
rather than going the other way and
making something into the world
your Hawthorne effect was so so
interesting I'm glad you you brought
that up because there is you know how
many times I've thought about of this is
what I had to silence myself when you're
speaking how many times I've thought
about putting a camera in the studio
that is constantly on and constantly
streaming what I'm doing in the studio
to the internet because if that was true
I promise you I would not masturbate I
promise you I would not eat refined
sugar I promise you I would work out
more I promise you these things are true
I promise you I would probably work more
mm-hmm
I bet you all of those things are true
because and what do you what do you
think about that it sounds horrible
oh my god
what can we have fun like or whatever
like
like but just like I don't know like go
over to friends houses I'm like tonight
is off the record right and like wait
I'm like I mean like like literally off
the record like no foot you can't take a
photo you can't tweet anything tonight
because like we're just gonna talk and
have fun and do whatever and it's off
the record like it's sort of I'm not
saying it's Vegas you know in the
microcosm I'm just saying like like even
don't repeat it like just like well but
let it live like let's live in this talk
have dinner what about the asymmetry
that Nassim Nicholas Taleb talks about
where your private life is different
than your public life and that asymmetry
is actually unhealthy because then
you're a different person in those two
scenarios well I would argue the same
way that I needed to write books in a
certain voice and then express a
different part of my personality this is
how people actually become whole is
through that dualism I didn't an ideal
world sure you could be yourself at all
times
but who goes to work where they get to
be themselves entirely right I'm almost
there
I would say yeah well getting there
that's it's great like I think is people
I think some people people get more when
they get more comfortable that's right
and they don't feel like they have to do
this self presentation things yeah yeah
but I'm not talking about like people
want to make fun of other people or be
mean or swear or or do drugs where I'm
not talking I'm just totally you know
being themselves and to some extent the
I think people they balance their psyche
out by by it's a way to manifest their
full self so yeah it's not isn't is it
is it unhealthy yeah it hurts like who
hasn't like had a job and been there for
a long time and felt like I'm a shadow
of myself here and that's why they have
weekends and that's why they have
weeknights and you find a way to live
like that
like that's
it's far from ideal I certainly feel
like Moe people are becoming we're
getting better and better with that
there's a lot less of that
self-presentation requirements and
workplaces and stuff and much more
acceptance yes but yeah there's still a
lot of it what do we do about you you're
you you know there's plenty more to
discuss where you left off about
non-fiction writing and creativity in
fact being mushed together that found
that fascinating it's a lot of what I'm
writing about I want to want to talk
about that but I also want to talk about
how we move forward in the attention
economy with the new cycle being the way
it is and with authors trying to have
this profound synthesis that stays on
the radar longer than a short blip you
know etc what is our yeah what does our
means to figure out how to move forward
I don't know I just try to like
gravitate like I recognized the problem
and then I watched myself kind of
migrate and move I don't really have
like a thought of a plan of attack but I
do believe that every organization every
company is now a media company yeah
everybody has to tell their story you
can't wait for the press to come to you
so if everything is a media company
including media companies and media
companies like my publisher is just a
big French conglomerate trying to make
its margin and its return on invested
capital just like Goldman Sachs is like
there's no [ __ ] difference at all
like and and you know if if Fox and
Disney owned everything like in media
like there's no [ __ ] difference it's
just a corporation trying to get
returned that's a capital buy like suck
and stuff out writers like it is what it
is so I don't
to me that's liberating on some level
and it'll freeze the writer from the
construct that you have to do something
the or or that sort of like right now
there's like a pay scale right so like
if you if you do your own podcast you
can have total creative freedom but if
you want to get paid you got to find a
way they like Sunday be Terry Gross or
something right like so or or have you
know shows with million audiences like
every day every week like that's where
the money is because of the volume but
those are just corporations just like
anything else and the so I feel like
it's liberating to think you can go
right with or for any organization not
just a media organization it's like
we've freed the writers from the I mean
people are groping and groanings are
groaning around like the lack of money
for writers and that the media pays you
know one quarter what it used to pay or
whatever but like it's true but on the
other hand we've been freed from this
construct that we had that we only write
for sort of media entities and if they
somehow freed from the naive idea they
somehow have like they don't have to
make money like anybody else does which
now they do you know and I feel like
that that opens the gates just saying
let's go write for anybody and everybody
let's go show let's go find
organizations who we like and let's
partner up and let's work together let's
let's co-create yeah you know any
entering media has made it also so that
media needs to make click baby stuff
which makes it so that their fact is
being distorted disinformation is
occurring money and disinformation are
go hand in hand in many ways which is a
very unfortunate yeah yeah I wanna hear
I wanna I want to ask you and even
though you live your life finding the
solution hopefully we can continue
aiming to disseminate what is the
optimum optimal for for children I still
think one of the major things is to
spend less time on
more time creatively endeavouring
finding meaning from making what do you
think in terms of where you were at when
you were talking about being creative in
a nonfiction setting so you had to have
creativity and fact you know you were
talking about that that was fascinating
and then after that you know that so
these are basically like major exits on
your career where you went took a
pit-stop
absorbed information got back on the
road and continue driving yeah yeah so
tell us some more about the pit stops
along the road because these are really
interesting well I've never I've never
known where I was going next
I've never knew what the next guy I meet
these riders for like I've got my next
six book plan I'm like wow you know like
but like I I never know and no one in my
life knows and when I do they're usually
like what do you mean you're gonna like
what like who would listen to you about
that like because I don't know anything
and I start a project I just sort of
like gravitate to it and I start
learning stuff and I start talking and
researching and maybe I write an article
and then all of a sudden like stuff
starts to happen but like I it's it's
it's a weird thing like it the thing is
I guess on some level I don't think of
it this way but there has to be some
incredible trust in my own creativity to
think I'm gonna figure it out to sort of
literally free myself people who don't
mean well say like I'm better at
forgetting things than anyone they've
ever met like I'll I'll go back with my
books like you look at like how did I
ever write this thing every word is well
chosen every sense like it's incredible
like how did I ever write that I can't
imagine the amount of work that would
take yeah and even though I lived it I
look at it like oh my god like how did I
do that laughs yeah how deeply
concentrates so hard for three years to
absorb so much and get it right yes
and and then after two years of
promoting it or something and travel in
the world and cross languages and stuff
and then to walk away and just create
this white space and say I don't know
what my next books gonna be and I you
know I went as the books did what well I
you know maybe had enough money that I
didn't have to worry like where I was
gonna eat or how I was gonna pay rent
think I'd still have to worry about my
future and doing other stuff how would I
ever buy a house or I would ever have
kids it was may not even be necessary to
do today yeah yeah but but back when I
was doing it that was a fear but and
it's not really a fear anymore but the
just creating that sort of blank slate
again I I think I was saying this to you
a little bit the other day but I
remember when I started writing for
Wired in the mid 90s maybe it was 96 97
they they sent me to do a profile of
Danny Hillis mm-hm who had done Thinking
Machines back in Boston and he was just
beginning to think about doing the long
now and the clock that would last 10,000
years as to why and I thought was a
great weird idea but I know how to write
the article right and I went down to see
Danny in LA and the first thing he said
to me because I was probably like 31
years all the time right and so I don't
know how old Danny is but he was older
than me right he'd be maybe 15 years
older and he was like you're pretty
prolific and he was basically gave me a
warning that like your creativity and
your prolific mess the enemy of that the
thing that will steal it is you get
older it's not your age your mind is not
it's not any different your mind is
anything just gets sharper sharper and
better but it's distractions it's
distractions
and it's distractions which manifest it
in a thousand emails a day yep it
manifested people calling you it's
manifested in someone becoming sort of
popular or well-known suddenly everybody
wants you to speak or do this or do that
there's a good interesting just example
of what you're saying is when someone
calls you there's this fascinating
calculation that you're doing in your
head of where you rank on the hierarchy
where they rank on the competence
hierarchy whether or not they are gonna
be asking you for something whether or
not they're able to provide value or
you're able to provide value whether
what you're doing in the moments
actually more worthwhile
versus if your phones on silence and
different rumor it's off you didn't even
know that call happened but almost
always it's true that they're calling
you at a convenience yeah it dis
convenience for you for correction and
that's again a hidden asymmetry yeah in
daily life that occurs yes I only have
seven people in my life I'll answer her
phone for because because of that like
you have to find ways to create space
for thinking for thinking and you you
know that's so interesting Danny talk to
us yeah Danny taught me this and it was
like and and I'd be like I was sort of
like man you know like I didn't get it
and then it was like as stuff continued
to happen and suddenly the world wants
you to travel and want you to speak and
once I was like Danny you're right like
and I literally it took me two years to
write the article to figure out how to
write it but in that paying time I was
stuff was happening and I would be like
tena you're so right the first day I met
you said this to me and I yeah at the
time I didn't quite get it but already
over this two years I do and you know I
mean that's just one way to look at this
problem that we're talking about which
is this incredible need that if you want
to have real thought you have to put the
other stuff down and find defense
mechanisms and sometimes it means being
a bad person in other people's eyes it's
true you know it means like respectable
as that's that's against the rules that
you don't answer the call and so-and-so
calls you know like or don't look at
emails like how people think I'm blowing
them off like I don't read anybody's
emails anymore like it's just like why
like it's just a distraction like of
course I want to talk to people I love
people I love everybody like you have to
find what a yeah and create space
especially for like a book like totally
does anybody have that kind of time and
it's ridiculous that we're ending the
conversation on time because time is
such a fascinating topic it's something
I'm absolutely obsessed about time can
in a very universal way time is the most
valuable commodity or attention to being
the most valuable commodity but also in
a multiversal way time is is happening
all at once and however we can try and
wrap our monkey minds around these
things is is I think we'll talk about
that next time we sit down we'll talk
about automation and civilization and
psychology all the things we were
talking about tonight so falling out of
the economy the labor force yes how
people are gonna be living in the future
I want to talk about that the 80% on the
bottom of the socio-economic strata and
how they're moving extremely slowly
forward and they don't own assets and
how the top 20% at least owns some
assets and the top 1% of that holy cow
they own almost all of ass yes so
there's some insane stuff that's um that
is going on and with automation
happening I've been talking about
species species bifurcation for a while
so I'm I'm excited to talk to you about
all that Poe and continue learning about
the rest of your journey at the same
time so thank you for there sit down
thanks ma'am yeah that was so fun it was
really fun though yeah we got plenty
more to talk about soon thanks everyone
for tuning in for this first interview
with Poe we'll be back we'll be doing a
multi
Amrish udon another rush on another show
with PO soon thanks for tuning in give
us a comment below with your thoughts
we'd love to hear from you also go and
create go and do go and manifest your
destiny into the world go build the
future much love everyone thank you for
tuning in and we'll talk to you soon
[Music]